i was taking this thing that i believed
and knew that i was very good at and
that i cared about and i was trying to
use it
to convince this other part of me that i
was not an irredeemable piece of [ __ ] so
if if i had enough people saying to me
what you did was really important or if
i had enough of a sense that i had made
a difference in doing this thing or that
thing then i would feel redeemed enough
to no longer feel really terrible about
what kind of human i was but i never
stopped thinking that i was really
really good at being a politician i just
didn't think i was much of a human and
that's why i needed to do as much as
possible as a politician so i could
prove to that other part of myself that
i was not irredeemable
[Music]
so
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to ford the new york times
bestselling author for a second time of
the invisible storm which is a
tremendous book military veteran former
army captain now president of expansion
of the veterans community project jason
kander joins us welcome jason well
thanks for having me andrew i really
appreciate it man thank you i should
have introduced you as fellow
presidential candidate in 2020
we uh this is the first time we've ever
like
met we've talked before i mean this is a
close to meeting this counts uh in
post-covered world this this is meeting
um but you we like crisscrossed in iowa
a couple of times where i know i spoke a
couple they're like andrew yang was here
earlier and i was like oh
so it's kind of funny oh yeah so i'm
just going to do some some scuttlebutt
around the 2020 race so check it out
anonymous entrepreneur andrew yang's
like i'm gonna run for president and
then i'm like who else is running for
president and your name was
at or toward the top of the list it was
like you know he's running for president
jason kander and i was like oh let me
check out this jason kander fellow and i
was like wow he's really impressive he's
the guy who put that gun together
blindfolded in that ad
that's that's that's me man that's how i
to this day that's often how i get
introduced you know i dare say if that
if there was anyone and you know i'm i'm
friendly with him now but it's like it's
anyone who should have been breathing a
massive sigh of relief for you not
running
was mr pete bootage because if you'd had
two
young
charismatic military veterans in the
midwest running
you guys would have been like head to
head i do remember pete called when i
announced that i was going to run for
mayor instead and functionally you know
took myself out of the presidential
field
and pete and i were already friendly and
i remember he called and he was very
plain about it he was just like look um
i was looking at it anyway but obviously
you and i were in a similar lane so
you know he he just kind of talked with
me about here's my strategy and i
remember being like oh okay interesting
and you know to his credit he brought
that to fruition man like he
it was like you and he and you know
biden and what
com who was who was there at the end it
was like just a few of you yeah uh amy
klobuchar elizabeth warren bernie
but
there were seven of us wandering around
those last stages
i
dare say that if it had been you and
pete i think that you would have
occupied a lot of the same energy and
appeal and you know you and i didn't
know each other that well so when you
did decide to run for mayor i was like
huh it looks like one fewer presidential
candidate and and then
and then it hit the news that uh you
were going to be seeking treatment for
ptsd which is what your awesome book
is about and one of the ways that you
can tell how good a book is is based
upon how honest it is and your book is
breathtakingly honest i was like oh my
god
yeah i am literally an open book at this
point i mean it's it's uh once you break
the seal as i did on october 2 2018 and
tell the world that you uh
have ptsd symptoms and that you have
suicidal thoughts
after that
i don't know for me it hasn't been as
difficult to
you know be really forthcoming uh and
really candid and in some ways in some
ways it's it made the book easier
because
you know after i did that i went and i
got i got treatment and about six months
later and i'm sure we'll get into the
whole story but about six months later i
was done with that real phase of
treatment and i was just
you know ready to go on with the
post-traumatic growth part of my life
and that's what i've done but i
recognize that in the zeitgeist like to
the extent that people still you know
think about jason kander which i don't
know how much they do and i care a lot
less than i used to which is really
freeing well i mean you're finding out
that they do given that your your book
just premiered to the top 10 in the new
york times but continue no that is a
good point that is nice but my point is
is like to the extent that you still
exist in the zeitgeist you're aware in
my case that like the last thing people
heard was hey man i'm really messed up
like i have suicidal thoughts i gotta go
so there's something really
uh
i don't know
liberating
yes thank you there's something really
liberating about being able to say to
the world like well here was the journey
i went on here's the journey i went on
after that
so that you don't feel that sort of
sense of like uh sympathy projected onto
you by the rest of the country it is a
little bit nice to be able to to shake
that off and be like okay it's nice for
people to get to the end of the book and
know like i'm actually doing great well
i i
want to
applaud you and you you've gotten this
from thousands of people for helping
uh to normalize people seeking treatment
for mental illness veteran or
non-veteran i mean that the fact is that
everyone struggles
yeah and it's something that
we all too often keep to ourselves
and one of the reasons why reading or
book was for me in particular a jarring
experience is because you get into the
nitty-gritty of just how much being a
political figure beats up your personal
life
beats up your health beats up your
mental health and i've lived a version
of that
my version is much less arduous than
yours because i kind of uh catapulted
myself into you know
you took a bit of a shortcut which is
you know good for you you you were look
man if i had been able to do that i
would have like if if there was a a way
where i could be wait i don't serve in
the legislature i just run for i just
signed up for that deal
so good job you
well well thank you jason
my wife thinks so too no um but one of
the reasons why your book is is so
honest is because your your wife uh
writes certain passages uh and
you've wanted to help people and be in
politics uh your entire life uh and you
won your first state rep race it seems
like just by old-fashioned shoe leather
yeah um when i think back that's my
favorite of all the campaigns um
and it was just it was a race for state
representative where we knew
that
i was lesser known and i really and i
didn't know any of the players that
you're supposed to know right which is
uh
you know that's the usual underdog story
i guess in politics but i was 26 when i
started running
and so we figured well there's 8 000
houses in this district that are really
likely to have primary voters in them um
so how about we just meet all those
people and i just come back from
afghanistan where i was i didn't realize
it at the time but it was the first of
many times when i was like oh cool an
opportunity to occupy my mind with
something that isn't intrusive memories
and thoughts
that sounds great so i jumped right into
that and i ended up knocking those eight
thousand doors two and a half times so i
stood on a porch and knocked on the door
20 000 times in a year and
you know despite being the candidate
nobody expected to win that race because
we met everybody like more than once we
won with 68 of the vote so i think this
is a very very powerful and important
lesson for people who are interested in
politics uh i had an aide who did a
similar thing
where he
became the youngest
uh elected official in the state of new
york
um because he was a college student and
simultaneously decided to run for state
rep so even had you beaten by like a few
years
and it was the same thing where
if you have a finite number of doors to
knock on um you can just outwork the
other people particularly if they
are kind of
complacent incumbents just chilling and
like they don't really know what's going
on and if you're the average voter
you're like well the young person who
knocked on my door seems to care about
this job more than this person i'm
barely
heard of that know what's going on so
maybe i'll just go that direction i mean
one of the most common things i heard
was uh wow
nobody's actually shown up before or or
the other version i would hear of it
which was always interesting was because
you know there's 163 state
representative districts in missouri so
it's kind of funny that it worked out
this way
several people before me my predecessor
in my state rep district was claire
mccaskill so it was the same district
that claire had represented like 20
years earlier and claire you know has
since become a very good friend and i
knew her a bit then
um but it was so many doors where people
would say to me
wow
the last person who knocked on this door
uh was claire mccaskill who at the time
that that i was running
you know uh first state rep she was you
know already in the in the u.s senate so
um you know and they would they would
just be like wow that that's the last
person who and i've had a bunch of state
reps since then so it means a lot to
people when you show up yeah so you win
that race uh just by out working and
then your next race is a secretary of
state race that it's too big for you to
pull the same trick
and then there's a more senior
legislator
who's going to bigfoot you out of that
race
has got money he's got the relationships
been there a while and at this point you
haven't been there very long you're
still in your 20s i think and you
somehow managed to
get him to back down from running
against you which i thought was one of
the neatest
magic tricks i've heard of
yeah well it was one of those things
where
and it's part it's really the first time
in the in the book where i kind of let
the reader see
what i was dealing with behind the
scenes and how i took that low level of
simmering anger that was kind of always
there as a result of um
ptsd which i didn't know it was at the
time
and i channeled it into something which
you know in that case what it was was
yeah all of a sudden um this guy he was
the county executive in kansas city so
he had a huge constituency compared to
my little constituency and he'd been
around a while um and he decided yeah
well maybe i'm running too and he had a
full-time staff you know like campaign
staff you know and i was a state rep who
had like a legislative aid at the
capitol but that's not campaign staff
and i knew i was going into this meeting
with him and he was thinking well this
is where candor comes in and we work it
out he steps aside and i was thinking i
ain't doing that i was so mad that this
guy was running when he told me he
wouldn't i mean i was more mad than like
really the situation called for but that
was how i was sort of learning to
control
my emotions not even that it was more
like i had learned i didn't know this
then but i had learned in afghanistan
you control the situation around you and
if you don't you die so i had this need
to control everything and i was i
learned later turning to anger as a way
to feel and control so i go into this
meeting and in order to look like i
might actually be somewhat intimidating
and have some sort of
team in place i called a buddy of mine
who was a first year law student and i
was like hey can you just be a pretend
campaign aide your fake aid i love it
yeah and so this guy brian he meets me
at a walmart across the street from the
starbucks we were meeting
i get into his car sit in the passenger
seat he drives 300 feet to the starbucks
gets out he's got a blazer on he's got a
notebook he sits during this meeting
doesn't say a word
and i basically lay out like look you
can run but i'm running too and i'm
going to outwork you and this ain't
going to be good for you and it was
supposed to be like an hour-long meeting
but it lasted six minutes and two days
later he called and was like yeah you're
right not the right race for me and it
was having no idea that brian went
immediately back to class right after
that meeting and i had nobody working
for me at all
you know what's underrated in our health
and mental health sleep and you know who
makes an awesome mattress to help you
sleep better he likes
the helix mattress became everyone's
favorite mattress in the house and in
these days we like to personalize stuff
helix sleep has a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and will match you
and your body type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you soft
medium firm hot cold yes that's a thing
how you sleep on your belly on your back
if you're looking for a mattress take
the quiz you'll learn something i did
and you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress for the best sleep
of your life 10-year warranty try it out
for 100 nights risk-free i know it's
weird to return a mattress after 100
nights but you can do it and helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
yang that's
helixsleep.com yang
[Music]
oh and what i loved is as soon as that
meeting ended you just uh called
everyone you knew to to roll out a
couple of endorsements that could help
pressure him out of the race
uh it's really
you know one of the most elegant pieces
of political jiu-jitsu i was aware of
because ordinarily there is such a
hierarchy and this person's ahead of you
in the totem pole but you managed to
elbow him out you then become i want to
say the youngest statewide elected
official in the country uh and then
national headlines start homing in on
this uh up-and-comer in missouri
yeah i uh i hadn't known that i was the
first millennial to win a statewide
office but i found out when they started
writing about it and that got me a bunch
of national attention which was exciting
for a lot of reasons but it also gave me
yet another thing to sort of
uh distract myself something to focus on
it gave me this national attention this
opportunity to i mean you know the
adrenaline rush of like when you're when
you're doing a remote cable interview or
whatever and you
you know you know they're about to come
to you on national tv
that
adrenaline
you know i hadn't had any adrenaline
like anywhere near
uh the level of afghanistan so long and
this was you know wasn't afghanistan
level adrenaline but
i was addicted to it and i just kept
having to go to these
performance opportunities to get these
you know these highs these endorphin
highs i've done my share of those remote
cable hits and they are an adrenaline
dump because you've got an a voice in
your ear saying three
two
one
mr kander
like blah blah blah blah and then you're
like okay i'm not going to address
hundreds of thousands of people or
millions of people and and on some level
you know that if you [ __ ] the bed uh you
could
you know go viral make yourself uh
laughing stocks set your career on fire
etc etc or even underperform and then
the people around you are like hey that
wasn't so good um so it actually makes
you you feel like there's a like a kind
of a
combat instinct yeah and then when it
goes well
like that's a great feeling right and it
can last a while and and the other piece
of that was like
you know i felt like particularly by the
time later on that i'm like soft running
for president every one of those felt
like very high stakes right because i'm
you know
you're certainly familiar with what it
is to feel like a lot of people are like
this guy like do we think this guy is
qualified right i felt that way i was
you know i had been a statewide official
but i wasn't a governor and i was 30
what 37 years old or whatever and
i was i felt like each time i was like
okay gotta go be presidential gotta go
prove myself and that was that was a
challenge and an adrenaline hit in it in
itself
yeah so the the thing that uh really hit
home to me about the book is that you
talk about the internal struggles of a
lot of this
which most people don't
appreciate or recognize and one of the
things i will share too is that what we
just joked about hey i just kind of kind
of catapulted myself in the national
scene and you're like hey if i had done
that too um the truth is that the wear
and tear of
this kind of work over multiple years uh
like i didn't have that i kind of showed
up fresh and then i don't know like felt
my way through it
so i had an accelerated version of it um
certainly there were times when the
weight of the world felt like it was on
my shoulders because like oh [ __ ] if i
screw this up then hundreds of thousands
or millions of people that have invested
some kind of hope in me are about to be
disappointed which does become an
immense amount of pressure
um but i only felt that for a relatively
brief period of time
and someone who's been in politics for a
while feels some version of it for a
really long time but your book catalogs
kind of this
cumulative wear and tear
uh it puts on you and that's something
that i'm not sure people really
appreciate where you look at political
figures and say hey why do they seem so
abnormal
uh and then there's part of me that's
like well we're putting them in really
really abnormal roles and over extended
periods of time that'll probably mess
you up it's why it's always made me
laugh that one of the highest
compliments people give politicians is
he or she just seems like a normal girl
or guy right because like no one has
ever described their accountant as like
you know just really down to earth
that's why i like my accountant you know
he's she's got both feet on the ground
right but but when as a politician when
people say you know you just seem normal
it's like the oscar of our business i'm
the best uh
like actor around
right it's like what you seem normal is
like the medal of honor of being a
politician there's nothing greater than
that right and and i've always found
that funny but you're right the reason
is is because it is it is a rather
abnormal experience like you are going
out and you are in a perpetual job
interview in every part of your life
you're at the grocery store someone
recognizes you boom you're back in a job
interview and so i do think that can
have that can have an effect on people's
mental health i think the reason that it
was so appreciably more pronounced for
me
uh is and this is yet another thing i
learned in therapy is that my brain
learned
that that you must control every
situation that's what it was like to go
into these meetings as an intelligence
officer with people who it might be
setting a trap so you got to know where
are the exits how many guys between me
and the vehicle you know once i get
through this exit if i have to fight my
way out
well you're trying to control it all the
time
and then all of a sudden you know you
come home
and there are threats but they're minor
threats you know it's to your career
it's to your schedule that day whatever
but your brain in my case my brain had
learned had not really learned to triage
those threats again like it had before i
deployed so it was like everything was
ringing the bell at the top everything
was the threat of dying
and it's why
i would frequently say to my wife things
like i feel like i'm dying and it made
no sense to her but it was the only way
i could describe the emotion you know i
kept telling myself that there was
something really wrong with me and it
made me dislike myself that i was
struggling to triage and and treat those
things as all they were which was just
they were just career things that's all
they were they were there was what was
going on with my work but my brain and
my body were reading them as if somebody
who might want to kidnap me
had come into the room
and it was in therapy that i learned why
i interviewed a comedian shane gillis
recently and he said something about i
asked him what proportion of comedians
do you think hate themselves
and he said all of us
but we also think we're awesome
and i heard this
and i thought to myself like i wonder
how many politicians that applies to
and and i want to share you know my own
story so like i'm the son of immigrants
and
my parents would put some pressure on me
and i i
felt
uh angry and marginalized as a kid i had
some desire to prove myself or chip on
my shoulder for most of my 20s now but
by the time i decided to run for
president i was like a dad and like a
fairly fully formed adult and like i
feel like
you know like i've resolved
some of the things um but for for you
your book talks a lot about how
um you'd be super angry at yourself
uh and i'm i'm wondering how much of you
think this applies to politicians writ
large given that at this point you and i
have both met a lot of them i think it
applies to a lot of politicians and i
think you can go even wider than that i
think it probably applies to to the way
you started this with the comedian to
people who in some respect perform right
who give speeches who who are actors who
are
broadcasters
i think there is some piece of that um
for a lot of us and and the piece i'm
talking about is the split the the
dichotomy between
potentially very high self-confidence
but not high self-esteem
and and that's how because i've been
thinking about this a lot lately the
part that it took me a while to figure
out was you know my self-confidence my
idea of my own skill set never flagged
at all right i mean i was a guy who
despite the fact that i had this growing
sense of self-loathing which for me
manifested as a sense that i hadn't done
enough in the army that other people had
done so much more and here i was with
these problems and who the hell was i to
have these problems i didn't deserve i
didn't earn it you know
but i also never
never
ceased to feel like
yeah so i'm 26 of course i should be in
the state legislature yeah i'm 31 of
course i should be the secretary of
state yeah i'm 34 or 33 whatever i was
when i ran of course i should be a u.s
senator i'm 37 yes i should be president
of the united states well in the
meantime i'm in my mind like i'm an
irredeemable piece of [ __ ]
but
i was also like but nobody's better at
this than me
uh so
it is a a really interesting difference
and
and
you know i obviously talked about it
with my therapist a lot and
and he sort of helped me see that
i was taking this thing that i believed
and knew that i was very good at and
that i cared about and i was trying to
use it
to
convince this other part of me that i
was not an irredeemable piece of [ __ ] so
if if i had enough people saying to me
what you did was really important or if
i had enough of a sense that i had made
a difference in doing this thing or that
thing then i would feel redeemed enough
to no longer feel really terrible about
what kind of human i was but i never
stopped thinking that i was really
really good at being a politician i just
didn't think i was much of a human and
that's why i needed to do as much as
possible as a politician so i could
prove to that other part of myself that
i was not irredeemable
[Music]
your
profile goes truly national when you run
for the u.s senate
in in 2016 that's when this famous ad
that you and i referenced about you
taking apart a rifle blindfolded arises
uh you raise uh i'm sure millions and
millions of dollars
uh just about every national figure
comes and tries to stump for you
and you outperform democrats or hillary
clinton specifically by some whopping
margin like 16 points
uh in missouri which unfortunately is
not enough to win in part because
missouri has gone from being a
perennial swing state
um to
red i mean right now it's uh republican
plus
nine maybe something along those lines
why do you think missouri has gone
from purple to to red over the neck the
last gosh i guess it's been like you
know 10 or 12 years well i like to joke
that we just officially joined the
southeastern conference like we used to
you know we mizzou football and
everything used to used to be like it
was us against nebraska you know now
it's us against auburn so like our
politics and our our colleges went that
direction our college went that
direction but
you know obviously there's more to it
and i think when you look back on when
missouri was a bellwether state which
lasted like 100 years
um you used to be able to take like a
map of the united states and lay it on
top of missouri and in terms of
demographics it looked very similar
right like the east and west coast of
missouri kansas city and st louis that
that's where your greatest population
density was and then in the middle you
had columbia missouri which college town
you had some population density there so
those were your very blue areas and they
were they were they outnumbered the rest
of it on top of the fact that
demographically uh and also from an age
like uh
stratagem perspective we just lined up
exactly with the country and that's why
it was so frequently the case that so
went missouri so with the nation well
our demographics changed over time the
state got older
and more than anything the latino
population in missouri didn't grow like
it grew in the rest of the country and
so as a result we sort of slid into
being more like those other states in
the southeastern conference you know
before that it was like iowa and
missouri had very similar politics right
and then after a while it was like okay
and i was now become pretty red but you
know for a long time it was like okay
iowa has this rural
populist progressivism and then it was
like okay well northern missouri is like
iowa and southern missouri is like
arkansas and then eventually it just
became like missouri is a lot like
arkansas yeah so i i had a thesis
on this in the presidential um so it's
not just
missouri as you pointed out iowa also
quintessential bellwether that now is
republican plus nine
ohio uh purple is the day is long and
now it's republican plus eight and so
uh one of the main things i saw was that
we'd eliminated 4 million manufacturing
jobs many of which used to be in these
states and so it's been harder for
a high school educated
man
to be able to make a middle class living
for
himself and his family
in a lot of the midwest
and the south
and that trend really took off around
2000
and then you started to see
the these
states reading up during that time one
of the the things that does make me sad
and angry is that if you're the national
democratic party
and you look at what's happening in
missouri or iowa and ohio or ohio you're
like wow we used to be really
competitive here and now we're not uh
and you obviously lived this because you
were you know the democratic senate
candidate in 16 and you'd again like
outperformed any uh anything else in the
party but the national democratic party
can just look up and say that's okay
we'll just swap these states for
arizona georgia uh and virginia that are
you know getting um more diverse and
then we can give up on missouri ohio and
iowa and i'm just like wait a minute
that like that's bad for the country
it's like you know like theoretically it
also tends to polarize us more because
uh you know it it bifurcates us more in
terms of urban rural or
uh white and and diverse not only does
it cause us to be more polarized i also
think that what it does is when you say
it deepens the problem because like in
terms of your political problem you make
it harder and harder to win it back
later it's not like you can just set it
aside and go well we'll come back to
that if the demographics change because
as david axelrod likes to say all the
time if you tell someone that uh they're
not your voter they will believe you
right like so when when you when you
stop talking to the needs uh or the
concerns of certain people and you kind
of act like well you're probably you're
probably for the other guy they're like
i guess i'm probably for the other guy
or gal what frustrates me about that is
that
you know like i'm very much a democrat
because i look at the democratic
policy you know spectrum and go yeah i
think i agree with almost all this
where i get irritated is that this
debate that we keep having in the
democratic party which is
the wrong debate we keep asking this
question of should we move more to the
middle or should we just tack all the
way to the left is that how to get these
voters back and i'm like we are asking
the wrong question
my neighbors in kansas city do not look
at joe manchin and alexandria
ocasio-cortez and see two people with
different ideological sets they go okay
so they're both democrats like you you
either you sink or you swim together
right so it's not a question of how
progressive are you how not progressive
are you it's are you talking about the
things that concern these people now we
are talking about things health care
guns all this stuff that will make a
difference in these people's lives but
we're not talking about it the way they
think about it where i live what people
are worried about is
and you just spoke to it with the
manufacturing issue is are my kids going
to have to move somewhere else in order
to raise their family in order to be
successful because that means i'm going
to have to choose
if i have the means to choose i'm going
to have to choose whether to move to be
with my grand grandkids or stay in the
place that i call home
but that's that sounds like a very
practical thing what it really is is is
my family going to be together am i
going to be able to keep my family and
the people i care about whole yeah
and and that's what frustrates me is
that
the reason that people
in my party think that this is about
going left or going right you know on
the left spectrum going center or going
left
is because it's
it's not that like they're from the
coast and so therefore they're too
liberal which is what people think it is
no it's like when they're from new york
or l.a or whatever the problem is they
live in the place our kids move to for
opportunity so they're less likely to
understand that this is the concern that
we have to speak to
no the the tough thing is like you're a
parent now and congratulations on your
uh your your daughter uh how old is she
now she'll be two in september yeah yeah
so that that also hit home for me
because there was a point when i was
running for president and my wife and i
were talking about
trying to
have another child
and there was a period when it was like
well like i don't know if we can do that
given uh what i'm doing
um and it seems very clear to me that
your decision to
uh step away from the trail uh it was
vital for your mental health it was
vital for your marriage but it also is
almost certainly uh you know responsible
for your having a baby girl now
you're absolutely right like
my wife was like
i'm not i'm not doing this again on the
course that we're on and i couldn't
argue with her you know yeah yeah so i i
saw that as like a very very uh you know
big win
for sure that that speaks to your mental
health andrew that you saw it as a win
oh but but again i mean a lot of this
book you can probably tell like i found
it very very relatable um though though
i will tell you jason i was a little bit
uh frustrated at the dates of some of
your therapy sessions because i was like
man i was like slogging it out in iowa
new hampshire
i'll tell you that was really surreal
right because here i was i thought i was
going to be out there doing the same
thing at that time and so
here i was like
i have a weekly therapy session and
nothing else on my calendar and i'm just
like trying to figure like learn like
okay how how long do you put a salmon in
the oven right like but
like how long do you put a salmon in the
oven and can i concentrate on that long
enough to not think about this other
thing whatever it is this intrusive you
know traumatic memory and then you know
i'm just doing this homework that my
therapist gave me during the day but
like i'll be at costco
and
like you know
kamala harris will call me to talk about
veterans issues and i'm just like a
stay-at-home dad it was very confusing
right it's like trying to figure out
because we're all doing that all the
time right we're all writing our own
story we're all the star of the movie
that we're in
and so trying to rewrite that story for
myself at that time was a confusing a
confusing thing yeah so after your
senate race because you outperformed the
party so much
everyone was looking to you for advice
and guidance you found yourself thrust
into
presidential contendership and you're
like hey wild like you know like i i uh
didn't even think i won that last race
yeah exactly
president obama
invites you uh to meet with him in dc
and you guys shoot the [ __ ] for an hour
and a half by the way never happened
with me so thank you president obama
hey man it's not too late
no i know you mean he he called me after
the the race and i met him in the white
house a couple of times it's fine so you
sit and meet with him uh for an hour and
a half and he talks about you're running
for president so that must have been one
of like the points where you're like oh
[ __ ] i think i'm gonna do this thing
yeah it was it was like um you know what
it was for me at that point was as as
much self-confidence as i had about as a
politician
um i was still aware that like you know
i still had some imposter syndrome for
sure about the idea that i was
you know not exactly
out of central casting from a resume
standpoint for running but
you know so when when a guy who was my
political hero a guy who
you know i had so much respect for
it wasn't like it wasn't like he was
like you're the one you know he was just
like
it could be you like you do have the
skill set like there are other people
who it could be but like he wasn't like
this is a bad idea you know he was like
i could see this
and
to have that sort of validation it meant
a lot to me and and it had a lot to do
with me going like all right i'm gonna
do this because i just had so much
respect for him
for him to treat it like it was not a
bad idea it was big for me so you're
gearing up for the presidential run but
at this point
your
ptsd is manifesting at higher levels
and you make what i think is a very very
brave decision
to seek treatment and then also share
with people why you're seeking treatment
become a role model for at this point
probably hundreds of thousands of
uh veterans and their families probably
millions of americans and you improve
through treatment
you're chronicling your own treatment i
thought was tremendous because it was
again very
honest
uh and optimistic if someone does the
the work like they actually can start to
understand their own brains and feelings
feel the feelings uh as
uh yeah as nick would say
that's right yeah man it means so much
to me that because look i've done like a
lot of these interviews and not
everybody gets the chance to read the
book beforehand so i i really appreciate
it
once i decided and it wasn't like i had
like a long
a long process as you know from reading
the book of deciding to step away it was
just like things have been getting bad
for a really long time
and then they
they just started getting worse a lot
faster and i was scared because i was
having these suicidal thoughts at a
greater clip than before
and it got to a point where i was like i
can't do that i don't want to do this
anymore and and i
and i didn't want to want to die so once
i made that choice i you know i i talked
with my longtime campaign manager and
with my wife and it was like okay i had
some options i could i could say that
well i'm just stepping aside uh from the
mayor's race because let america vote is
so important right now or i could you
know there's a lot of different things i
maybe could have done
but i felt like you know what
i hope that i'm able to get better but i
also felt like
i feel like if somebody had done this
a long time ago maybe i would have tried
to get treatment a lot earlier so i just
thought well i want something good to
come out of this and so that's why i
decided to be public about it at the
time i pretty well figured i was pretty
sure that i was ending any chance of a
political career
because nobody had ever really done what
i was doing or at least anybody whose
mental health issues had become public
had never really had a career after that
it was scary because it i i was okay
with trading that in uh at that point i
had no choice but to trade that in to
get better but i didn't actually know if
i could get better but i just decided
you know
if this will help somebody then that's a
pretty good public service and
so that's the choice i made uh
you helped destigmatize seeking
treatment for mental health i mean it's
no exaggeration to say that you saved a
lot of lives um uh you saved another
bunch of lives through the afghan rescue
project which we can talk about so i'll
just speak for myself because i think
that's the most comfortable thing
when i was a teenager
my school referred me to a mental health
counselor because i seemed
angry or angsty or lonely or brooding or
something like that uh i
enjoyed it i got a lot out of it uh i
looked forward to it uh she at one point
was like look i think you're fine and so
you know this would be our last session
and uh we we hugged
um but ever since then i was like wow
everyone should do that
um because
like like
like how does it do anything but help
and then my brother has become
a psychology professor
whose work centers on stigma and mental
health wow and so i've always been a
very passionate believer
in
seeking mental health treatment in the
fact that
mental health is health
countless lives are destroyed or
diminished
as a result of the fact that people
aren't seeking the kind of care
but i'll also say that as someone who's
been in the public eye
your instinct really cuts against the
grain of what most anyone else does in
your situation
um because you're just so used to
trying to present a certain front to the
world
uh and that and so i i okay i'll just uh
more me
but like there have been times where i
did not want to be doing whatever the
[ __ ] i was doing
[Laughter]
you know
it's like i i don't particularly want to
like uh you know show up to the this
event spar with this reporter like do
this debate you know like like um answer
the same questions over and over again
maybe maybe i would like to be with my
family
yeah yeah it's like or it's like hey i
can sense that like my wife is
struggling and here i am like you know
three time zones away like uh trying to
tell people how great i am or how
important this campaign is you know like
there are a lot of behaviors that's a
really important thing you just said
that dichotomy of
i feel like i'm not holding up this my
end of the bargain in something very
important to me my marriage
and
what am i doing right now while i'm not
holding up that end of the bargain i'm
telling people how great i am like it
that does take a toll like it it can
make you feel
pretty bad about yourself
yeah
i mean it it can become very unhealthy
very quick
i mean the best part of my campaign was
when my family showed up down the
stretch which was like two years in um
my wife had a running joke that she only
shows up if i get to three percent
[Laughter]
you know what's funny though is that
like you just said two years in peop
there's people listening to this who
clearly you know they listen to your
show they follow you a lot they they
they're yang gang or you know they know
this stuff who probably are like wait
two years because just the same way
people say to me like oh i discovered
you with the gun ad or oh i you know
your podcast
and you exist in people's consciousness
from that point forward that they but
what they don't realize is
you ran for president for two years
right like
i i didn't even end up running and i was
soft running for president for like a
year i i ran for the senate for almost
two like
it's just interesting that i think
people don't realize that it's a
non-stop endeavor for way before you
ever realize that we're doing it yeah to
your point jason it makes you appreciate
people who are in it for a while because
like as a candidate or an official like
you know what it takes
let's say that i make a presidential
debate stage and then people like ah who
the heck is this guy or you know what
not it's like well to get there like i
had to go through a lot of [ __ ]
yeah man
every every every dinner in iowa every
you know three people are gathered and
you're there you know in my case it
genuinely was three people for quite
some time whereas you would have had a
crowd waiting for you jason one of the
things also in your book that that um
frustrated me there were a lot of things
in your book that frustrated me
but what was you start this organization
let america vote and it has
massive operations in like new hampshire
and iowa i started a non-profit
uh and i can prove to everyone uh who
wants to look that i had no intention of
running for president because we never
went near new hampshire or iowa even
though we were in like 12 states it's
like oh if i'd had my [ __ ] together i
would have gone to manchester and iowa
city
you needed my more pathological need to
avoid myself
so your your journey uh is genuinely
saving lives uh you know like
i mean it's totally clear
uh
and
you have daughter
you know you're coaching your son's
little league you're playing ball you're
actually physically healthy when before
that you were grinding yourself in and
you're back into dust and
you're also
i referenced it earlier but you started
the afghan refu uh rescue project that
managed to get a thousand afghans out of
the country uh when the u.s pulled out
yeah um
yeah so what happened is is you know i'm
like a lot of other vets afghan vets in
the country who just still had people
there right
last august when
everybody's trying to marshal their own
folks together and then get them into
the airport because that was really the
only way out of the country to avoid
taliban retribution um but it started
with just me and then it was a couple of
my battle buddies and then eventually
there were quite a few of us and we
weren't able to get our people into the
airport and in fact uh we were trying to
get our people into the airport and
working with the marines on the ground
when the bomb went off and so it was
really upsetting obviously
and then
you know the last planes left and my
buddies and i made the at the time
probably ill-advised or i don't know
impulsive decision to be like we're
still going to get you out having no
idea how the heck that would work
but yeah we ended up
getting everybody up to masri sharif
where the taliban hadn't fully
consolidated control yet and then
raising a bunch of money to charter a
full airliner to fly into mazaru sharif
and then holding like literally hiring
like a caterer and and and holding a
fake wedding for four days in masuri
sharif so that we could put everybody in
one place you know the way that it was
working at least at that point was it
was like if the taliban found you and
you were on their list of people they
were looking for which all of our folks
were
then you know they got to be the taliban
kill you take you to prison whatever but
if they if they didn't find you until
you presented at the airport with a visa
and like on a manifest to fly to another
country well then it was an
international incident if they killed
you and they were trying to be somewhat
more they're somewhat less isolated than
before
and so it was like this terrible game of
like tag or capture the flag where you
got to get physically into the airport
with this document and then you're safe
and so that's what we that's what we did
it worked on that first one and then we
realized we could maybe keep doing this
so we raised a bunch of money and
ended up doing a bunch of flights and
actually at this point i think we're now
above uh 1800
people um who we've helped get out and
it's
you know i never did anything like that
when i was in office so it's
really easy for me to look at things and
go like yeah i think i have a much
greater impact now
again saving lives who the heck gets
1800 afghan translators and their
families uh out uh jason kander does
it was kind of an accident but i mean i
i appreciate it it was it's genuinely
some superhero [ __ ] jason uh and and now
you are
uh trying to get more veterans uh the
help that they need and as someone who
ran for president i met personally
hundreds of veterans
uh who um were struggling truly uh i
heard horror stories about the va
you know and it was tough because these
were
men and women who'd given so much of the
country uh you know and now you're
trying to
help many of them too
yeah um i'm in now the best civilian job
i've ever had as as president of
national expansion at veterans community
project um i actually just i'm sitting
i'm talking to you from a uh from a
hotel room in st louis because i'm doing
a book event here tonight but just an
hour ago i was at the site of our new
campus that we're building here in st
louis and it's just so cool i mean it's
like what we're building here is a 50
unit like 50 tiny homes village with a
community center and an outreach center
so we'll be able to take homeless
veterans move them into our village get
them full comprehensive wrap around case
management services
which and then
that's part of our whole system that has
an 85 success rate of then getting them
successfully into permanent independent
housing but then our outreach operation
is this whole other part that people
we're less known for but uh that our
people are less aware of but it's just
it's what the va really is meant to be
which is any veteran can walk in with
any issue and we will work with a
community partner to solve it it's
actually how i got involved i i was
running for mayor and i got the vip tour
of the the you know mothership campus in
kansas city which at the time was the
only campus and i was blown away by it
and six weeks later i'm on suicide watch
in the er at the va
and the and the people at the va are
saying like hey we're ready to help you
you've got to enroll in the system it's
going to take a few months and i'm
thinking like i don't have a few what
yeah seriously about suicide watch here
and it wasn't that they didn't want to
help it's just like you know there's the
va is full of awesome people who are
hamstrung by the system and so i call my
buddy who was the co-founder of veterans
community project and the ceo and who
had given me the tour and i'm like hey
man i'm announcing this thing tomorrow
that's probably going to be pretty big
news and i'm saying i'm going to the va
but the va just told me it's going to be
months before i get in i don't know what
to do and he's like well come on down
here so i go down there and i end up
walking through the outreach center uh
walking into the outreach center just
like thousands of other kansas city vets
no different and they expedited my
paperwork like they do for others and a
week later i had my first therapy
appointment at the va
so i was already a believer now i'm a
super believer in the program and six
months later i've been going to weekly
therapy i'm doing well i'm hanging
around all the time because i was just
inspired by it
and uh and i had been giving them advice
because all these other communities were
saying hey what you've done in kansas
city is not been done anywhere else can
you come and do it here and i had you
know let america vote i'd created a
national organization before so i'm just
kind of giving advice and finally my
buddy brian uh who's the ceo is a ceo
said to me like hey you ain't working
you're just hanging out here like how
about you just come on full time and uh
and so that that's what i did and now um
i you know we
we are right now building a village in
the denver area we've been serving
veterans there for a year like i said
we're building in st louis we just broke
ground in sioux falls south dakota we
just bought land in oklahoma city and
then we got some other stuff laid on for
after that so it's a great gig i love it
it's really awesome stuff man and the
fact that you made the right choice for
uh your yourself and millions of
americans and veterans uh and your
family
it's still not the same kind of choice
that a lot of other people make you know
like i mean that this thing will
um
we will
uh eat some people alive um and and so
reading your book really like i i think
you can tell like i felt it pretty
deeply it's like but like i appreciate
uh the leader and person that you are in
ways that i know a lot of other people
will as well so the obvious question
that people have is like hey you know
and this is an awful [ __ ] question
you know what i mean but but it's the
entire it's like look you know i'm doing
awesome work like things are great it's
like but then there's always like the
the
what's next question sure um and it
seems and you were a surrogate for the
biden campaign they wanted to rope you
back into washington um did you and
diana seriously consider uh making that
move no not really i mean we we knew
that um
that it was possible that they would
reach out and say like hey do you want
to be considered for the cabinet or what
and so we had talked about all that and
you know and it's
once in my case like once i had kind of
cleared out a lot of the mental health
cobwebs that were
you know motivating me for the wrong
reasons before
uh it was just so much easier to make
clear-headed choices and it's like hey
our son has an awesome friend group i've
got this great job uh i you know i i
love doing what i'm doing i'm enjoying
my life combined with in the past
i
thinking about the future all the time
and planning out my political future was
really like that was what i turned to
for medication it was like that was my
self-medicating if i could be thinking
about the future all the time i didn't
have to be in the intolerable present
but now the presence is great and so we
didn't really seriously uh consider we
sort of like fantasized about what it
would be like for a couple of days and
then but not in like oh that would be
great just sort of like
let's kick it around and it was like no
we were right it's not something that we
want to do right now uh and one thing
that does happen jason that you do write
about in the book as well um is there
people around you that you feel
responsible to and for
uh and sometimes uh you know and that's
one of the the things that i don't think
people appreciate about political
figures is you kind of feel like you
need to be making progress because there
are people who bet their lives and
careers on you and you want to create
opportunities for them absolutely i
think in that way you know like i've
never been an entrepreneur my wife has
but i think in that way
you i think you would agree that it's
similar right it's that that
in in that case it's like
you know you're more worried about
meeting their payroll and and that kind
of stuff but in but in this it's like
this is there they have a political
career too you know and so
um i'm really gratified that the people
who were in my sort of closest circle
politically that they've all gone on to
do great things and they're doing really
well but there was certainly a period
for a long time where i felt very guilty
about that that they had they had put
all their chips in the jason kander uh
you know bucket and i don't think i got
that idiom right but you know what i
mean oh no we know all their eggs in the
jason kander basket yeah um and i had
been like hey uh i'm gonna take this
basket over here and coach little league
instead and i don't need a staff and so
i felt very guilty about that for a long
time
well you shouldn't jason and i think
that's really one of the big points you
can tell i took some life lessons from
this book it's an awesome accomplishment
it's going to touch and inspire
tons of people and i do think that this
book is going to save lives
so please do be proud and anyone who's
listening or are seeing this invisible
storm a soldier's memoir of politics and
psd by jason kander a real american hero
and someone who's going to keep doing
amazing things in and outside of
politics i'm sure for as long as he's
breathing thank you so much jason i
appreciate the heck out of you thank you
i really appreciate andrew this was fun
thanks for doing this
you